so now let's think about i talked about
what the fed's bailout proposal is is
that they essentially want to take 700
billion dollars and use that to buy some
of these smelly assets these cdos that
have on that a lot of these banks have
on their balance sheet and that which
which have been kind of the cause of why
a lot of these banks
are going under or at least why a lot of
the banks aren't lending to each other
and we said you know i kind of touched
on the last video that you know that's
in my mind maybe it solves the problem
but if it does even if it does solve a
problem we'll address that in this issue
but in this in this video but it seems
like a really horrible thing to do
because if you were to buy these assets
that are worth let's say they're worth a
zero you pay two billion dollars for
them you're essentially writing a check
to the equity holders of this company
the shareholder of this company who
bought you know they they benefited from
all the reward and of of the last five
years of getting the returns on that
stock price and the dividends and
whatever else and now all of a sudden
when things go bad they don't bear the
risk the american taxpayer bears the
risk and so you're writing a one billion
dollar check to the equity holder and a
one billion dollar check to the
liability holders of the people who lent
this company money
and you've probably heard the word moral
hazard bantered around
moral hazard
and this is as good of a time as any to
explain what people mean by a moral
hazard well there's a couple there's one
just the superficial notion of hey you
are writing a check to the very same
people who made bad decisions right the
people who lent this company money made
bad decisions and the equity holders of
this company made bad decisions one the
people who invested in this company they
didn't they didn't realize the risk and
also a lot of the equity holders are the
management of the company and they're
the very ones who invested in these cdos
and if you were to essentially buy out
these cdos you're not penalizing them
for making bad decisions they get to
keep all their bonuses before maybe they
get to keep their job still and you're
propping up their stock price so that's
one element of moral hazard the other
element of moral hazards and this kind
of this is a more nuanced notion
but it's in some ways the more important
element of moral hazard and that's if
the government goes in every time that
there's some type of financial stress
right all these people took risk they
had they got the reward already but when
the risk starts to hit the government
goes in and make sure that these people
don't have to don't have to deal with
their consequences the moral hazard
there is is in the future people are
going to say you know what i'm going to
take risk because
if when times are good i'm going to make
the money and when times are bad we've
seen it multiple times the government
the us government is all too ready to
come out and bail the bailout the
private sector so you you create this
moral hazard well even the you you're
making these bubbles more likely to
happen in the future because people are
not going to be as concerned as about
risk because they're like look at these
idiots they took all the risks in the
world they bought cdos that people lent
money to these people who bought cdos
they were levered up and the government
even bailed out these dudes so i can
take huge risk i'll get all the reward
from in the future the government's just
going to bail me out and that's the
other element of moral hazard well
anyway with that decide and i would
argue that there's a lot of moral hazard
with the government's current bailout
proposal maybe that moral hazard is
worth it
if it prevents this chain this cascade
of events from happening if somehow it
allows people to start lending to each
other and most importantly start lending
to the real world like the guy who wants
to build the factory or the farmer who
wants to
borrow money for seeds for next year's
crop
now what i've heard and i don't know the
exact numbers here and i'm not an expert
here is that
there's about
i've heard the number been about five
trillion dollars of these toxic cdo's so
one the
on on all of these financial
institutions bank balance sheet so i
don't know if that's the accurate number
but i do know for sure 700 billion is is
a is a relatively small fraction of the
total amount that's out there and
bernanke and paulson they're essentially
arguing no no i we you know we know 700
billion it doesn't represent all of the
cdos out there even if you were to buy
them at a discount but what we're hoping
to do is by going out there and with a
large amount of money
and and starting to buy these cdos
that'll hopefully create some type of a
market in these cdos and they talk about
doing a reverse auction where we'll say
okay we're ready to buy 100 billion in
cdo's so whatever banks whatever banks
are willing to give us a hundred the 100
billion dollars worth of cdos at the
best price those are the ones we're
going to buy from that's a reverse
auction you go and you say i want to buy
who's going to sell to me for the
cheapest price and so that's what they
said by doing that maybe it'll create
other other other private interests will
say hey the government's getting a good
deal on these cdo's i want to buy into
and maybe other people will start buying
the cdos the reason why i call that crap
is because if other people were there to
buy cdo's they would buy them already
and when and the bottom line is when you
do this type of reverse auction when you
say oh i have 100 billion i want to
spend on cdos
paul said in bernanke they're arguing
that that would somehow create some type
of market price for these cdos that
these that these banks could then mark
their assets and everyone will know what
they're worth
two problems that will not be a market
price because you're creating artificial
demand artificial demand from the
government if the government wasn't
there there wouldn't be this hundred
billion dollar
entity wanting to buy assets so the
assets would go for less and then the
second thing is what if the government
does that and people realize that these
two billion dollars of ceos even when
the government does this reverse auction
are actually worth only um i don't know
these are only worth
500 million right that's what people are
willing to unload them for and it'll
probably be the more solvent people who
do it because for them it won't make
them go bankrupt well if they're really
worth 500 million then every other bank
that holds the same things will have to
write these this 200 million down to 500
million this 2 billion down to 500
million and so their equity will get
wiped out and the cascade will start
over again so i don't buy it on two
counts one i don't think it'll actually
create a real market price that anyone
would believe i don't think it's going
to make anyone jump into the market all
of a sudden frankly if someone thought
these were good deals there are a lot of
very very sophisticated investors out
there who have a lot more knowledge
about what these assets really mean than
frankly the treasury does
and if they thought they were good deals
i guarantee you there is capital out
there where they would go in and buy
these assets for what they thought is a
good deal and hold them to maturity
there is cash out there and i think
that's a an important issue that people
don't realize a lot of people are out
there holding cash they're holding
treasuries they just don't want to
invest in these because they are bad
deals people are looking for a good deal
but these are most probably not worth
much they're probably worth nothing
so
what is another solution and this is
something that a lot of people have have
bantered around a lot they said well
why doesn't the government just go
instead of just buying out these cdos
which is essentially just writing a
check to the very few the very people
who got us into the situation why not
buy stock in these companies so we we
talked about those situations with the
um the sovereign wealth funds right
where the sovereign wealth fund comes in
bought you know that example they bought
three billion dollars worth of of equity
and they gave three billion dollars
worth of cash and then the company can
use those to pay off its debt
that frankly is
not a horrible idea the only reason why
i would say it's still not a great idea
is you're diluting the shareholders but
what if this equity is worth zero right
what if there's actually negative equity
here if this is worth zero if these two
billion dollars are actually worth zero
then this is an insolvent company right
you have three billion of assets four
billion of liabilities this is actually
minus one billion of equity
so really the stock has no value the
correct share price of the stock if we
didn't have um limited liability with
corporations would be
the correct market capitalization would
be minus one billion dollars so why
would you pay a positive price for that
for those shares so even in that
situation if this is really worth zero
and the government were to buy shares or
buy a lot of shares and infuse this with
capital it would save the company it
would penalize the equity holders
because all of a sudden instead of
having 500 million shares you'd maybe
have two billion shares if you owned
100 of the company before now you only
own 20 of the company and that's
actually what happened with aig you
might say well that's a pretty good
situation but still the government's
taking a little bit of a hit and and
frankly if the government did that i
think the risk reward
might be reasonable there because if the
government were to infuse capital into
these banks if they were to so let's say
let me do the example let's say there's
500 million shares now
the government says you know what we're
gonna give this company four billion
dollars
so we're going to give it 4 billion of
cash
4 billion of cash and let's say for
those 4 billion
shares let's see if the current is for
those 4 billion shares
we want
i don't know we want another
let's make it like really intense let's
say the government wants
10 billion shares right so essentially
they're paying 40 cents per share so
then we're going to have 10 billion
shares here so that's 10 000 million
and we're gonna have 10.5
billion shares this is actually not a
bad situation for me so the company now
will have four billion dollars of cash
four billion dollars of cash three
billion dollars of other assets and now
the cdo's and maybe those cdos are worth
nothing
now no matter what this company cannot
go bankrupt because four billion dollars
of cash four billion of liability it
could pay off this liability with that
equity infusion
and that and and and and the people who
deserved to kind of take some downside
did get downside because the equity
holders they used to have 100 of the
company with their 500 million shares
now they own what is this this is one
they own 121st of their company so they
went they got diluted from owning 100 of
the company to owning what like yeah
like less than five percent of the
company so this might be a fair
situation although i would still say
even in this situation you are bailing
out the people who lent this money to
the bank right they they lent money to
an institution that they should have
known better than to lend money to they
said they're holding all these toxic
assets they collected interest on this
institution and right when the
institution was about to go belly up the
government does this huge equity
infusion and essentially takes over the
company makes it a part of the
government right because the government
now owns 90 something percent of the
company
and pays off the liability holders so i
would still say that there is still some
moral hazard here because in the future
people say oh i'm willing to lend maybe
you know you're you you're still hurting
the equity holders but you still be
willing to lend to an american bank
because you'd say when things get bad
the american government goes in and
bails out the bank by buying a bunch of
equity so
you won't properly price and risk in the
future
but if if if this does open up lending
markets and people start lending to the
farmer or to the guy who wants to build
factories then maybe this is worth it
and i'll actually you know
in my mind if if the government is
really not worried about the banks and
they really are worried about this piece
right the farmer who needs the loan or
the guy who wants to build a factory
that needs a loan why don't they take
that 700 billion and just create a fund
to lend directly to the real world to
lend directly to main street why don't
they just let all of these banks go
bankrupt go into bankruptcy they'll come
back and they'll come back leaner and
more efficient with proper risk measures
and the proper everyone will get
punished appropriately so that in the
next up cycle there won't be all of this
moral hazard and you have the 700
billion dollars that is going directly
to lend to farmers and and and companies
that are building uh capital equipment
and whatever and of course there still
is moral hazard it's going to get highly
politicized who do you lend to et cetera
et cetera maybe then you still do a
reverse auction but the bottom line is
if the government were genuine about
being concerned about main street they
wouldn't do they wouldn't use the 700
billion in this indirect way they would
lend it directly to main street anyway
see you in the next video